In all the long division problems we've done so far, we've gotten really nice
clean answers. Because we have gotten answers that don't have a remainder.
We've gotten a zero when we complete our final subtraction step down here. Now,
the reason this happened for every division we've done so far is that, each of
the things we've divided our original polynomials by, have been factors of
those first polynomials. When we divide by a factor, there's nothing left over
from the original expression that this doesn't go into. Well, what happens if
we divide by something that isn't a factor? Well, then we get some number down
here instead of zero. Whatever number we get down here is, as I said before,
called the remainder. But if the remainder isn't equal to zero, we have some
more stuff to think about. Let's see what happens. Earlier on, we were working
with the function f of x equals x cubed minus 4 x squared plus x plus 6. Now,
when we were looking for roots, or zeroes, we tried to see what happens when we
let x equal 1. We found out that plugging that in gave us 4. Since when we plug
this in we don't get 0, we know that 1 is not a 0 of this polynomial. And that
means, in turn, that x minus 1 is not a factor. I wonder what would happen
then, if we divide this polynomial by x minus 1? Let's find out. Here I've
written out all the different boxes you're going to need to fill in to complete
this long division. So please, write what belongs in each one, and then write
your final answer up here. Please note that I've put subtraction signs and then
parentheses around boxes. So make sure that you write the expression that
belongs inside here, given that the subtraction sign is outside. Also, don't
forget to bring down your x and your 6 from the original expression.